[Music]
degenerative disease is painful both
physically emotionally and financially
if you or a loved one has been affected
by any degenerative disease including
arthritis high blood pressure diabetes a
DD osteoporosis or cancer stay tuned for
a pioneering new concept in health and
longevity hello and welcome to the
undoing of disease what your doctor
doesn't tell you I'm your hostess Margot
Watson I'm here in the studio with trace
mineral experts dr. Joel Wallach and dr.
Gerhardt Strauss are glad to have the
gentlemen here Thank You Margaret
good to be here dr. Shazzer before we
spotlight the prevention of cancer and
other diseases can you tell us what are
the strengths of our current medical
system as it stands now as it stands now
we are absolutely excellent and
first-rate in emergency medicine in
surgery anything that has to do with
first-rate technical equipment in this
regard we are number one in the world
dr. Wallach for the last 30 years you've
been involved in biomedical research and
clinical medicine tell us what you see
as the major weakness of our current
medical system in America today well
it's very expensive and it treats the
symptoms rather than going at the root
cause of the disease it's unfortunate
this is true the human medical system
hmm are there medical treatments or
myths or recommendations of the past
that have been abandoned which have now
been found to be harmful oh absolutely
Margeaux the cholesterol thing is
probably the biggest fraud ever
perpetrated against American people low
salt diet SAR totally useless and
low-fat diets this has created more
diseases more physician caused diseases
now than there were 40 years ago there's
a lot of myths that you've discussed in
your lectures before that have been
perpetuated are there any other ones
that were really interesting I remember
some that chicken soup no longer is
valuable but if you run into your doctor
right well for instance myth that
diabetes is genetic that's what I call a
medical Kaka that's certainly not true
adult onset diabetes which makes up 85%
of the
medic population is actually due to a
deficiency of two trace minerals
chromium and vanadium and yet and this
has been known since the 1950s and it's
a tragedy and almost criminal that
doctors continue to tell people this is
genetic and their only course is to take
insulin for the rest of their life and
there are other options oh absolutely
absolutely the people can wean off of
insulin people can get rid of their
diabetes it's just a matter of some
education and doing some basic things
everybody can afford just pennies a day
dr. Wallach you are a guest to over a
thousand radio shows and numerous TV
programs across the country each year if
you were to compare the American medical
approach to other countries in the world
how would you rate it
we wouldn't rank very well when it came
to actual numbers margo although the
american medical system when it comes to
technology is the most envied medical
system in the world yet we don't set any
longevity records we rank 17th and
longevity by the World Health
Organization there's actually 16 other
countries whose peoples live longer than
we do we rank 19th and healthfulness
that means that there's 18 other
countries whose peoples live longer than
we do before they develop cancer heart
disease high blood pressure diabetes
arthritis osteoporosis we ranked 23rd
when it comes to live birth and first
year survivability of babies and we
ranked dead last in a survey of 32 top
industrialized nations when it comes to
preventing birth defects we ranked 32
out of 32 so what this means what these
basic numbers mean Margo is we have the
highest price health care system in the
world but not the best what I thought
was because of our American system the
capitalism stress is that but it's not
that no it's an ignorance in the medical
profession dr. Wallach has a
veterinarian and physician you've
launched quite a stir how did you come
to believe that most diseases result
from simple deficiencies Margo as a
veterinarian we learned that we could
prevent and actually cure diseases and
animals reduce the amount of healthcare
cost by using nutritional formulas and
that's basically because we don't have
insurance for them we don't have Blue
Cross Blue Shield major medical
hospitalizations we haven't come out
with that yet well they've tried it many
many times but it's actually cheaper and
more effective to prevent cure
diseases with nutrition and I tried to
get medical doctors in the medical
industry and people who are in a
position of authority in the medical
system to adopt this concept for human
beings was actually on 20/20 with Hugh
Downs in Geraldo before he got his nose
broke for the first time trying to get
this concept across but it wasn't
interesting to them and so I went back
to school for four years became a
physician and I practiced in Portland
Oregon for 12 years as a general family
practitioner I used everything I had
learned in veterinary nutrition of my
human patients and it works just like a
charm in humans in fact it works so well
that a lot of my patients used to kid
their friends and and their relatives
and they say look if you're not happy
with what doctors are doing for you go
see doc Wallach he'll treat you like a
dog but you get better excuse me for
playing the skeptic here but you said
the farmers and ranchers supplement
their animals food with vitamins and
minerals well for me it's hot it's not
hard to conclude from that fact that
their feed was lacking something
absolutely in a farmer of course is in
business and if he has to spend a lot of
money on veterinary care if he loses
animals to disease can't get him to
market in time he does lose money and so
he's learned through research at big
agricultural universities that by
supplementing animal feeds he's going to
keep his cost down and he's be much more
profitable supplementing yes what does
that mean well that means adding
vitamins minerals and trace minerals to
animal fees because they know that our
soils are deficient and plants cannot
manufacture minerals and so they have to
get them from the soil knowing that the
soils are deficient the only way to make
sure each animal even the weakest ones
in the group get the optimal amounts of
nutrition the only way is to put it in
the feed blend it together make pellets
that way every mouthful is perfect so
does that mean dr. Wallach that there's
a problem with our food yes I know you
don't recall this but there was a US
Senate to 264 and US Senate document 264
was very remarkable because it pointed
out very clearly that the American soils
were depleted of minerals and
nutritional minerals and as a result the
crops that are grown there the grains
vegetables fruits and nuts are grown in
these depleted soils are mentally
deficient and as a result to animals and
people who eat these mentally deficient
crops get mineral deficiency diseases
and the only way to prevent and cure
these nutritional diseases is by
supplementing with minerals now this
document is pretty scary
Margo because it was written and
published in 1936 1936 1836 we did well
at that time we began to put vitamins
and minerals and trace minerals into
animal feeds to make up the difference
unfortunately for human beings we got
wonder drugs at the time we got sulfa
drugs in 36 we got penicillin in 38
we got cortisone in 42 and everybody was
led to believe if we just if we just
give medicine enough money for research
and if we faithfully watched dr. Marcus
Welby MD every week they will find a
wonder drug for everything well you know
that's not true today I'm concerned
about my health I eat a low-fat diet
basically I exercise I avoid sugar and
caffeine and I don't smoke
and I try to get in a salad today are
you telling me that I still have a high
chance of getting a number of diseases
absolutely Margo because first of all
even in the best of times in history and
now and certainly in the future
minerals never occurred in a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth
and as a result the ability of you to
get all 60 of the essential minerals you
need which are 2/3 of the 90 essential
nutrients is less than you winning a
million dollars each day for 30 days in
Vegas it's just not going to happen and
so the only way that you're going to
guarantee that you're going to get
enough nutrients is to supplement and of
course we've tried this experiment for
200 years Americans as you point out
have eaten better than anybody we've had
the highest quality of food yet our
average lifespan is only seventy five
point five about half or genetic
potential for 120 to 140 and there are
people that live that old oh absolutely
there's six to ten cultures that were
written up by the National Geographic a
very reputable group of people who have
a great journal and they point out very
clearly that the oldest documented
living human being was a hundred and
sixty-eight years old when he died a
hundred and sixty eight you imagine lots
of golfing in that what do you feel are
some of the diseases you can avoid or
prevent by supplementing with minerals
dr. Wallach
well Ashley Margot according to the CDC
the Center for Disease Control
eighty-five percent of the hospital
admissions in
America are due to degenerative diseases
and these of course are due to mineral
deficiencies most of them this
represents an enormous cost savings if
we could prevent these things which we
can we know we can we're talking about
diabeetus which is due to a deficiency
of chromium and vanadium we're talking
about osteoporosis and arthritis which
are multiple mineral deficiencies
calcium magnesium manganese sulfur
selenium copper zinc and so on plus some
vitamins and then of course you have
cancer which we know we can at least
significantly reduce the rate of cancer
by selenium supplementation
how many minerals vitamins that type of
thing are we supposed to have we're
actually supposed to have 90 essential
nutrients
Margeaux those include 60 minerals at 6o
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and 3 essential fatty acids and
they're called essential nutrients for
two reasons number one our bodies cannot
manufacture then we must consume them
every day either as food or as
supplementation and number two if any
one of these essential nutrients is
missing for a couple of months or a year
or so we get on the average 10
deficiency diseases so 10 deficiency
diseases times 90 essential nutrients
it's 900 diseases that are preventable
with proper supplementation dr. Strauss
ur the most dreaded of diseases is
cancer one of three people will get it
in their lifetime and billions of
dollars are spent each year to treat it
can a correlation between cancer and
mineral deficiency be dropped
yes and selenium an essential element is
the key element that we will be
discussing today because there's some
really exciting new news available which
i think is a true gift to the american
people and this is a gift because it was
announced actually on December the 24th
of 1996 but few people probably watched
they look for their presence under the
tree and so we can talk about that dr.
schrott sir as the current president of
the world biomedical selenium society
you actually discovered more than 20
years ago that selenium is a highly
effective trace mineral for cancer
prevention why in your words is selenium
so important for cancer prevention today
selenium is an essential trace
this has been known since 1957 but my
work has shown that selenium is uniquely
able to prevent or delay the development
of cancer almost irrespective of the
cause of it and in this regard it is
becoming the most important element that
we have to protect us against cancer
besides numerous responsibilities in
your professional career you've also
spent a lot of time as editor-in-chief
of a leading journal on biological trace
element research why is cancer
prevention so important because cancer
is a major cause of death just think
that in the US alone last year five
hundred and ten thousand men and women
died from cancer therefore anything that
we could possibly do to prevent this
disease is important and should be done
now and people are really scared about
it too because I guess they don't know
what to do that is correct and because
cancer once you have it is so difficult
and painful to treat takes often years
and the end is very unfortunate to
everybody and the costs are very
formidable aren't they absolutely
doctor's trouser one of your major
research interests is the prevention of
cancer with selenium what evidence is
there to justify the use of selenium for
the prevention of cancer by now the
cancer protective and preventive effects
of selenium have been demonstrated in
virtually hundreds of different animal
experiments and we now know that
selenium protects not only virtually
against all chemical carcinogens but
also against cancer producing viruses
and this is something especially
important because more and more it is
recognized that viruses that often may
be hidden in the body for years
eventually may turn normal cells around
and turn them into cancer cells and
therefore it is of utmost important to
have something there that may even
prevent uncle Genesis as we call it by
viruses and selenium as an agent so even
if somebody doesn't have a genetic
predisposition
physician towards cancer they could get
it even then you could get it because
you could have the genetic information
or a virus in your cells which could be
activated but studies have now shown
that you can infect prevent this
activation if you get enough selenium
that's exciting news absolutely
this was actually shown in China where
there's a region north of Shanghai in
which liver cancer incidence is
extremely high and the major risk factor
in this area was hepatitis B which is a
virus and it was shown that with
selenium you could in fact prevent not
only hepatitis B but also the occurrence
of liver cancer in the population as a
world-renowned scientist and one of the
pioneers in selenium research what is
our own natural defense against cancer
one of the chief system that we have is
our immune system we have special white
blood cells that have the sole purpose
of killing abnormal cells that are
practically almost always formed in our
bodies for instance when you're out in
the Sun certain cells may transform of
course you don't know about this but
there are lymphocytes watching over this
and actually are killing these abnormal
cells all the time therefore to maintain
the function of these blood cells is
absolutely essential and what is now so
truly fascinating is that it has been
discovered that if you give people extra
selenium you can enhance the activity of
these cells so that they can kill five
times more cancer cells than they
normally could and therefore our immune
system is actually enhanced by this
trace element selenium and so it works
naturally and everything works naturally
and there no side effects in fact
they're only positive effects and we
will talk about some of these outside of
the cancer
but what evidence is there that selenium
actually prevents cancer in humans there
is what we call epidemiological evidence
which shows that for instance in areas
that are naturally rich in selenium
fewer people die of cancer and then
there are studies in which doctors have
collected blood samples of healthy
people stored them for many years and
then looked in that population for
people who developed cancer and then
they compared the serum blood blood
selenium levels and they found that
people who later developed cancer had
lower selenium levels before that is
when they still were healthy they
developed cancer and that gradually gave
rise to the idea that selenium prevented
cancer in humans and ultimately it led
the National Cancer Institute and other
agencies to fund a large-scale cancer
prevention study which was just
concluded this year and which we will
discuss actually shortly from now had
there been some actual selenium
supplementation trials with humans to
prevent cancer as I already mentioned to
you and there's the first human studies
were actually done in China one was done
with a large number of people in an area
in which a suffragist cancer is very
common and it was found that just a
supplement containing selenium vitamin E
and beta carotene would significantly
lower the morbidity and mortality of
that population the trouble with that
study was that involved three agents and
so people are scientist as we are
skeptical and we wondered is it this or
the other but then there was a second
study including in the area was high
liver cancer incidence where only
selenium was used and was found to be
effective and now we have the search
study done in the United States with
American patients and their only
selenium was given and selenium was
indeed found to be effective do they
call it a wonder drug well you could
call it that I would call it a
1 the nutrient because the selenium in
all these studies was given at
nutritional levels and this is actually
a very important point we must never
confuse prevention which deals with
keeping your cells normal and healthy
with a therapy which involves a medical
intervention where you have to correct
something that has already gone abnormal
or cancerous so we will talk today
exclusively about prevention the best
way action before reaction exactly dr.
Chasseur what makes this study so
exciting
in my view it was that the age of the
participant was older than I would have
expected to lead to a successful study
because the average age at the beginning
of the study of the participant was
sixty six point four years at that age
you would think it's maybe too late to
start preventing cancer and yet after a
period of seven years of this was the
average observation period it was found
that in those subjects who received the
selenium supplements the cancer
incidence and mortality was up to 50%
lower than in the control group which
only received placebo that's exciting
and moreover what turned out to be for
me even most amazing that even a
terrible cancer like prostate cancer if
afflicting Elva elderly men was very
significantly prevented by just one
agent an agent that is inexpensive to
obtain and doesn't produce any harmful
side effects whatsoever I think this is
a study that the American people need to
know because it really opens the door to
it's an effective mechanism of cancer
prevention much simpler than anything
anybody would have thought in the past
and it's taken so long for us to really
grasp that information we're so grateful
you're here
have there been in any unexpected
results there have been not really any
truly unexpected results but I should
caution that the original aim of that
study was to see
patience and in fact the participants in
that study they are all farming skin
cancer patients the purpose of that
study was to see if you could protect
these former skin cancer patients from
developing metastases on new skin
cancers and that didn't work the lesson
we have to take from this is the
following if you had cancer it is
possible that your body harbors
transformed cells now these cells are
usually more resistant and they are
different you can say category than
normal cells and there a simple
nutrients such as selenium is not
sufficient to cause a true effect we
need additional measures therapeutic
measures but that doesn't mean that
selenium shouldn't be taken you just
have to watch out if you had cancer this
is a more serious matter and you need
medical attention you need additional
therapeutic modalities to protect
yourself against occurrences so the
bottom line is really a balance to
wisdom in using traditional methods and
also nutritional methods exactly and you
have to very well be aware that
prevention is something else than
therapy and it's best to prevent first -
and absolutely after practice what are
the consequences of this for anyone who
had cancer and now wants to take
selenium I think anyone should now start
can now start taking selenium it is only
that those people who already had cancer
still require the regular medical
check-up and additional treatment
modalities as I have already pointed out
it is reassuring to see that one can
prevent prostate lung and colorectal
cancers but what about breast cancer and
other cancers that afflict women now the
American study which was directed by dr.
Clark from the Arizona Cancer Center and
which involved thirteen hundred and
twelve participants unfortunately didn't
use enough women in the study and the
reason was that they totally randomized
the study they didn't know
the the gender of the participants so
unfortunately that study didn't produce
enough good data for breast cancer
prevention but our own studies have
shown that breast cancer can be
prevented in animals with selenium very
well and I can even show you a paper
that was published as early as 1915 in
the United States where they treated
actually breast cancer patients with
selenium successfully unfortunately that
study was forgotten maybe it was World
War one what one really has to watch for
breast cancer prevention is that one has
to begin taking selenium as early in
life as possible and that is because the
malignant transformation of the cells in
the mammary gland can occur early and
these transformed cells often sit in
little nests for years without doing
anything but these malignant cells and
later could actually develop into tumors
and for that reason I strongly recommend
start with selenium as early as possible
and of course you must maintain always a
regular medical check-ups
self-examination all methods that are
available to detect memory tumors as
early as possible because it's always
the case that some cancer cells can form
we sort of escaped the screening system
of the body so to summarize it is still
necessary to watch out very carefully in
spite of taking selenium but please do
take selenium and another thing one has
to consider is diet I often tell women
who ask me what can I do to protect
myself so half jokingly I say by a
Japanese cookbook and switch to a more
Japanese diet because we know that in
Japan the breast cancer mortality and
incidence is remarkably low but as now
Japanese are starting to eat more
Western styles American food
that's right the breast cancer incidence
is actually increasing even in Japan and
so I say let's turn around and say if
you are at risk of breast cancer you
think we are at risk start live like the
traditional Japanese do which is fairly
easy in the United States it's a rice
style seafood and but you also should
take selenium with it because we've
actually done a study where we gave mice
that had a mammary tumor virus is
simulated Japanese and the simulated
American diet and it turns out that the
American diet offered no protection
unless and until we added selenium the
Japanese styled offered some protection
but it became much better when we also
added selenium to that diet so the
answer is yes live like a Japanese lady
and take selenium that is I think a very
good recommendation we can make right
now with ethical justification dr.
Strauss er what is the opinion of the
National Cancer Institute and some
scientific peers on selenium as a cancer
preventive a few years ago I attended a
special selenium meeting at the National
Cancer Institute and there a
spokesperson said that selenium is
actually the only agent they had that
promise the only agent that's what he
said now again an agency consists of
people but I wholeheartedly agree with
him because you know there were other
agents that were touted for a while
beta-carotene for example which didn't
actually pan out in larger studies but
selenium has actually panned out and so
yes the National Cancer Institute
endorses the selenium studies however
they are cautious and in my opinion a
little bit too cautious in making
general health recommendations at this
time they want additional studies now I
ask you would you rather wait another
ten years before you start taking
selenium I would suggest that you don't
wait
taking no what's the downside if I did
take it and it proved that they did
these 10 years of research with nothing
10 the only downside of you taking
selenium would be that you could be
could not be a participant of the new
study but you would protect yourself and
I even wonder if there is not an ethical
problem now to conduct such studies
because I wouldn't want to participate
in the study where I would tell you or
without telling you give you a placebo
for the next 10 years and watch until
you devour breast cancer if I already
know that the chances would be high that
I could prevent you from getting the
disease and so these ethical problems
should be addressed and well I believe
we should take selenium and you should
take it when we come back we'll talk
about just how old you can live to be
and we'll talk with a sweet lady who
experienced a vitamin and mineral
miracle
[Music]
anga thank you for inviting us to your
home to sit and chat hearing about your
life and before and after your illness
tell me what did you experience when you
were sick what kind of ailments were you
facing and then what would you like
before I faced arthritis osteoporosis
chronic fatigue epstein-barr virus they
were told me I had fibromyalgia
I had my goodness Teradek Tamizh
his total hysterectomies what kind of
surgeries did you have I had fusions
down on my neck where they took the bone
out of my hip
I had knuckle replacement done because
he had such bad arthritis yes it
completely deteriorated my knuckles the
pain you told me was so incredible yeah
it was I took at roughly 7 vicodins a
day just to be out of do do some work
some functioning you know in my home and
you mentioned that the pain was so bad
in your leg that even the doctors were
suggesting yes I had very bad blockages
in my right Lake it throughout day and
night and they wanted to take the lake
off because of the pain and I also was
scheduled for more knee surgeries
chronic tendinitis carpal tunnel
syndrome just like you were falling
apart I I was that's what I did so it
impacted your life obviously physically
but also financially and mentally I went
through my life savings because of my
illness for eight years and had him
remortgage a house what was paid for in
order to build a new house double door
everything white open space so I could
be moved in the wheelchair and I could
function in that house had to toll it
put in a high toilet and open doors to
get into a shower everything's ready for
wheelchair and you mentioned to me
earlier that it got to the point where
mentally you just didn't want to face it
anymore no the pain was just so severe
that you just there
time you know you don't want to you want
to end it all so what was it change what
happened it to you that gave you hope
what gave me hope was dr. Wallach
listening to his radio show the last 12
minutes of his show he explained to a
woman she had osteoporosis of the spine
and I followed these rules
my son drove to the grocery store got
the gelatin we ordered vitamins minerals
Claudio colloidal melon minerals
everything liquid because you absorb it
so much easier and I start taking it day
and night I took a 10 15 times a day I
didn't think I could over do some
vitamins and minerals because I should
have been dead with all the medication
that took roughly 20 some pills a day
just to be pain-free
so from the time that you heard that
radio program and your son got the
medication yes when did you start
noticing a change physically well I kept
on taking a day a night and within 3 to
4 weeks my back didn't go out anymore
and nine to ten weeks after all that I
woke up one morning was pain-free I felt
for the first time in 10 years
normal I felt light as a feather and I
jumped out a bit and is that my god I
can move without any help I walk it was
like in your life yes I was like move
reborn so what are you like now what is
your life like me I'm a Hellraiser I
used to be I swim I hike again with my
dogs I do what I want to do again and
you credit it to dr. Wallach and the
minerals the vitamins the colloidal
minerals and the gelatin and a lifestyle
you've mentioned oh yes yes I will
forever be thankful to him he changed my
life I just follow what he says Thank
You Inga we appreciate you sharing your
experience and we wish you all the best
in your new life
[Music]
wasn't that an incredible story gives
all of us a sense of hope
absolutely after seeing the amazing
results mineral supplements gave Inga
Reagan dr. Wallach should we just go out
to the grocery or health food store and
get any supplement or what should we
look for
well basically Margo we have to educate
herself and what a mineral is there's
actually three types of minerals number
one there's the elemental mineral this
is relatively low and absorption and
availability to animal and human being
only as an adult only three to five
percent
I took child maybe eight to twelve
percent and in the 60s we actually came
up with a form of mineral known as
chelated minerals this is because
farmers aren't willing to put a dollar
in an animal's mouth and have a 99 cents
come out in the manure so we learned
that by adding amino acids and proteins
and maybe even enzymes which are
proteins that do work to the elemental
mineral it increases the availability
tenfold but the way that animals and
people were designed to consume and
absorb minerals is in the colloidal form
colloidal yeah small particle size and
suspension and this is ninety-eight
percent available to animals and people
as much as 10 times more available than
the elemental form so basically what
we're looking for here for usability is
either the chelated some form of
chelated mineral or the colloidal
mineral dr. Chasseur what is the best
form of selenium for us to take for
absorption and to avoid toxicity the
best form is a nutritional form which is
normally found in plants and the
compounds you should look for is Cimino
methionine that's an amino acid which
has selenium in place of sulfur we call
the sulfur amino acid methionine but
plants also produce an amino acid if you
give them enough selenium which is
Cellino mezzanine and built that
selenium into the proteins of the plants
and therefore certain grains for
instance are rich in selenium serine
and this Selina Messiah name can be
found in quality supplements and that is
the selenium that we should be taking at
this stage for nutritional purposes dr.
Wallach if I don't get hit by a train
and I choose to supplement with selenium
and the other required nutrients my body
wants and needs how old can I live to be
well the fun thing is Margo we have the
genetic capability of living healthily
now to be 120 140 there's no reason why
you can't be playing golf and jogging
and having fun playing cards with the
girlfriends and the boyfriends and 120
140 human beings do have that genetic
capacity but I would be quick to point
out that the Americans don't do a good
job when it comes to longevity we only
lived to be seventy five point five half
of our genetic potential and so we do
need to consciously make sure we take in
all 90 essential nutrients so we can get
there from here which all of us really
want to do we have quality of life right
people don't want to be a shriveled up
prune hundred years old sitting on the
toilet all day so you don't have any
time to do anything fun like golf or
playing and so on so you do have to take
in all 90 essential nutrients so that
you can be helpful there there's no
reason you can't for instance Jeanne
Calment
this lady who now holds the record for
longevity and if about a hundred and
twenty-two she rode her bike for a
hundred and five years as a volunteer
librarian and certainly everybody can do
that if we just do the right thing
in conclusion dr. Strauss er how can we
prevent and survive cancer we can
prevent it as we have seen with selenium
and also and this is important with a
healthy lifestyle
we should not smoke we should not drink
excessively we should have a healthy
diet and we should watch for small
changes which occur and we should have
regular medical check-ups to see if
changes that we cannot observe have
possibly occurred and we should see to
it that these changes are observed as
early as possible with this package I
think we can successfully prevent cancer
in dr. Wallach how can we prevent or
improve these other diseases
like arthritis diabetes heart disease or
Alzheimer's
well again you picked out diseases that
are degenerative diseases that are
either directly or indirectly related to
nutritional deficiencies and dr. Strauss
appoints out very very well give up the
bad things like fried foods and sugar
and caffeine and excessive alcohol and
take in consciously supplement with all
90 essential nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
three essential fatty acids and of
course this includes
chromium and vanadium for the the
diabetes that includes selenium for
cancer it includes the calcium magnesium
boron and sulfur and chondroitin sulfate
for for arthritis and osteoporosis and
if we do these things we can have a
quality of life all the way up to 140 if
you or loved one has been affected by
any degenerative disease including
arthritis high blood pressure diabetes a
DD osteoporosis or cancer don't wait for
your doctor to give you permission
you've now learned many things today
that your doctor doesn't tell you so
take control of your own health
and give your body the nutrients it
wants and needs today
[Music]
thank you for viewing this presentation
and remember to contact the person that
sent this to you for more presentations
and books that go into greater detail go
to doc Wallach Mediacom and be well
these statements have not been evaluated
by the FDA these products are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease the opinions
expressed in this informational program
are the express opinions of Joel D
Wallach BSD VM and D are not a
replacement for proper medical advice
and treatment in all cases we recommend
you contact your physician directly
regarding any medical conditions